madam Speaker the President of the
United States seven weeks ago this
chamber voted to impeach him later today
senators of the power to remove him from
office but they won't
the Republican majority will ensure
Donald Trump will be acquitted some in
the chamber even called for a second
term what's the reaction of Speaker
Nancy Pelosi who initiated impeachment
as an attempted handshake is snug
mr. Trump's poll ratings are improving
partly because the economy is booming in
just three short years we have shattered
the mentality of American decline and we
have rejected the downsizing of
Americans destiny we have totally
rejected the downsizing we're moving
forward at a pace that was unimaginable
just a short time ago and we are never
ever going back the state of our union
is stronger than ever before predictably
his foreign policy highlights included
his orders to kill Isis leader Abu Bakr
al-baghdadi
and the Iranian general Qasem Soleimani
our message to the terrorists where you
will never escape American justice if
you attack our citizens you forfeit your
life the atmosphere inside the chamber
was workers open hostility from
Democrats over some contentious issues
but their party is fragmented the Iowa
caucuses were a farce the results were
announced 24 hours later they revealed
peak Budaj former mayor from Indiana
with a narrow lead over senator Bernie
Sanders the party establishment dreads
having him as their nominee but former
Vice President Joe Biden finished a poor
fourth it's turned out to be a good week
for mr. Trump he didn't even mention the
word impeachment
our spirit is still young the Sun is
still rising God's grace is still
shining and my fellow Americans the best
is yet to come thank you god bless you
and God bless
in an extraordinary act of defiance
Nancy Pelosi made clear what she thought
of the speech but her party needs more
than gestures to prevent mr. Trump
winning a second term in woods Sky News
Washington